The ending may be the most critical part of
a film.
It’s easy to forget about a few weak spots
in a movie that ends well, but a bad ending
can ruin an otherwise great movie.
Crafting a good ending is hard, so it’s
rare when I see a film that doesn’t just
wrap things up in a satisfying way but manages
to make it the high point of the film.
This is why my favorite thing about writer/director
Damien Chazelle is how he crafts an ending.
My favorite part of both Whiplash and La La
Land are their endings.
By exploring what these endings have in common,
I think we’ll learn a lot about what makes
them work so well.
With regards to plot both films have a pretty
simple ending.
There aren’t any complex plot points to
wrap up, there are no subplots hanging loose.
Because of this they’re both able to climax
with sequence that packages all the resolution
of the film into one scene.
In both films there’s a feeling that everything
in the film has been building towards this
MOMENT, this specific SCENE.
By the final scene in both films, the narrative
force can be summed up by a single dramatic
question waiting to be answered.
Not every movie can have that sort of simplicity,
and not every movie should, but because both
of these films do, it maximizes the emotional
punch of both endings.
The two sequences are almost exactly the same
length.
Both over 15 minutes, these are long sequences.
From the beginning of each, you’re waiting
for a finale and Chazelle keeps you waiting
for a quarter of an hour.
In Whiplash the emotional conflict is developed
between Fletcher
and Andrew.
We’re waiting the entire film to see Andrew
show his full ability and receive recognition
for how good he is.
Chazelle withholds this from the audience
for the entire film, and just when we think
we’re about to see it, we see Andrew put
down once again.
The same thing happens in La La Land.
The emotional conflict of the story exists
between Sebastian and Mia.
We are waiting for the moment when they end
up together happily ever after.
But just before the end, that idea is shattered.
By placing a negative false climax, in the
lead up to the end, Chazelle puts us on edge
in both films.
We realize the happy ending we hoped was coming
may not be.
The simplicity, length, and false climax all
work together to create tension.
And because of this tension simple things
begin to take on significant meaning.
The smallest emotion on a face, becomes magnified
by the emotional context.
These simple character interactions will be
enough to communicate what we need to know.
Neither film relies on any kind of exposition
for it’s ending.
We’re able to see, and most importantly
feel the climax of emotion.
Another reason these scenes are so powerful
is that they use music to communicate some
of the emotion
and tension.
Both the scene in Whiplash and La La land
are essentially music videos, but with the
context of 90 minutes of movie settings us
up for the payoff.
Then Chazelle does something really brilliant,
he hits us with a second false climax, he
lets us see the happy ending.
We can enjoy the moment, the music, and see
the characters get what they wanted.
But it doesn’t last.
Chazelle then answers the dramatic questions
by mixing these two climaxes together.
We got to see the happy ending, but not in
the way we were expecting too.
Chazelle drives home the reality of the situation,
reminding us of what it cost for the characters
to get to this place.
The emotion of the disappointment, and the
joy of the happy ending combine, creating
in the viewer the same conflicted emotions
the characters are facing in both endings.
We only have the option of feeling the answer
to the dramatic question posed, because it’s
never spoken.
When the payoff of each scene arrives, it
comes as a simple exchange.
Two close ups.
Non-verbal communication.
We only have the option of feeling the answer
to the dramatic question posed, because it’s
not spoken.
The power of the music allows Chazelle to
use silence for emphasis in these moments.
The final similarity is that both movies end
directly after the emotional climax.
There is no afterword, no time to come down
from the experience.
The credits just roll, and you’re just left
with the conclusion ringing in your ears.
This helps that climactic moment stick in
your mind long after the film has ended.
Thank you for watching, if you enjoy my channel
and content and would like to help support
what I’m doing, check out my patreon, where
you can get access to additional content,
like a supplementary video on Chazelle’s
endings, and deleted scenes from this essay.